Moin Leute
Kurz ich habe gerade ein Battle Bit Video aufgenommen
Vor einer halben Stunde
Ich habe das Video noch nicht fertig
geschnitten und gerendert, aber
Audioaufnahme ist fertig und Video
an sich, die Gameplays und so habe ich auch schon
Aber ich muss da noch ein bisschen was dran rum schnibbeln
Das werde ich dann entweder heute Abend fertig machen oder morgen nach dem Stream, dass es dann morgen Nachmittag am Start ist
Soweit der Plan
Und jetzt werden wir ein bisschen, ein bisschen Hacker-Man-Shit machen
Ich wollte Avalonia schon mal ganz lange ausprobieren, mal ein bisschen ausführlicher
Vor allem werden wir uns darauf konzentrieren, ob das
Cross-Plattformen auch
Cross-Plattformen hält
Also wir machen eine ganz simple Demo-Anwendung mit so ein paar Sachen, wo ich selbst noch skeptisch bin
Ob es das gibt, ja, müssen wir mal schauen
Ja, viele UIs machen wir nicht, wir machen ein bisschen Demo-UI und vor allem will ich gucken, ob das ordentlich läuft
auf Linux und Windows
Da bin ich, da bin ich wirklich gespannt drauf, weil
Es gibt, es gibt nicht viele UI-Frameworks und noch weniger welche, die das gescheit hinbekommen
Also insofern bin ich echt gespannt drauf, ob das was taugt
Bin schon übel skyped auf meine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung im September, habe schon zwei Schinken von Python runtergewirkt
Ich verstehe, was du meinst, du hast zwei Python-Bücher schon gelesen, ja
Ich bin auch gespannt, also die machen, die machen es tatsächlich richtig im Vergleich zu Maui, die malen ihre UIs selbst
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ich habe davon keine große Ahnung, ich habe das irgendwann mal vor vier oder fünf Jahren
und so ganz noch ganz neu war, habe ich das mal kurz angeguckt
Aber nicht sonderlich ausführlich, also ich habe weder eine Ahnung, wie man ein Projekt setupt, noch ob es vielleicht eine IDE-Integration
gibt oder irgendwas in der Richtung
Mal gucken, also ich bin, ich bin vor allem gespannt, wie das Cross-Plattform mäßig aussieht
Kann das auch Internet, das kann sogar mittlerweile WebAssembly als WebAssembly published werden, habe ich gelesen, ja
Wobei ich halt nicht so sicher bin, warum man das machen will, aber es würde wahrscheinlich gehen
Das wäre, also der einzige Grund, warum man das machen will, ist, wenn man hauptsächlich, sagen wir mal, Desktop-Fokus hat
Aber auch noch irgendwie Web abdecken will, was anderes fällt mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht ein
Ansonsten machst du eine ordentliche Web-Anwendung und wenn du Desktop abdecken willst, packst du die halt bei Elektron in ein eigenes Fenster
Aber es soll angeblich gehen, es soll angeblich mit WebAssembly funktionieren als Published Target
WPF, ich mag WPF nicht, weil WPF, WPF auch hoffnungslos Outdated, Overrated, Debated ist
Und Windows-Only
Leider immer noch das Beste, was es für Windows gibt, weil WinUI 3 kommt ja nicht in die, kommt ja nicht in Fahrt
Blazer, ich persönlich verstehe den Riesen-Hype um Blazer nicht, viele Leute sagen ja, boah, geilstes, geilstes UI-Zeug,
was Microsoft hier gebaut hat, ich meine, es ist erstmal hauptsächlich für Web gedacht
Mit, äh, man kann ja theoretisch damit auch, ich weiß gar nicht wie genau, aber man kann ja wohl irgendwie auch lokale UIs mit Blazer machen, das ist dann auch ein Browser im Endeffekt
Aber dieses, ich brauche die komplette Runtime im Browser und alles, ich weiß nicht, also ich habe Blazer mal angeguckt, als es neu war, ich war mir persönlich nicht so sehr davon überzeugt
Ich meine, allemal
Besser als MAUI, weil MAUI ist wirklich so eine Technologie, auf die habe ich gar keinen Bock
Ein Entwickler wisst bestimmt schon Bescheid
Ja, Web-Based oder Desktop-Based? Web-Based könnte ich ja noch irgendwie verstehen
Ich verstehe nicht, was Microsoft da macht
Das ist ja aus Xamarin, Xamarin, Xamarin, wie auch immer man das korrekt gesprochen hat, hervorgegangen
Aber der ursprüngliche Entwickler davon ist ja, also der Chef von diesem Projekt ist gar nicht mehr bei Microsoft
War dieser Spanier, wo ich den Namen nicht weiß, äh, Carlos, Carlos irgendwas
Aber wobei Carlos glaube ich so ziemlich der 0815 Spanischer Name schlechthin ist
Äh, Carlos irgendwas, Carlos Martos vom New York City, genau der war das bestimmt
Wie hieß der denn, Carlos?
Wie hieß der, der Xamarin-Typ, beziehungsweise, der hat ja auch .NET für Linux damals mit Mono aus der Taufe gehoben
Ikazas oder sowas? Nee, Miguel hieß der, warte mal, .NET?
Nee, nicht Miguel Indurain, das war ein Fahrradfahrer, den Typ meine ich, genau, Alter
Das ist ja der Erfinder von Mono, also quasi der .NET-Implementierung unter Linux
Und der hat auch Xamarin gegründet
Und Microsoft hat Xamarin gekauft, irgendwann hat drauf dann MAUI aufgebaut, aber der ist mittlerweile nicht mehr bei Microsoft
Der hat keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß gehabt
Und ich fand Xamarin schon abartig, aber MAUI ist noch ekliger
Keck W
Ich aktualisiere mal kurz meine VM, das brauchen wir heute auf jeden Fall
Leute, heute, wir machen Console-Only
GUI ist outdated, overrated, 800x600
Console ist das einzige, was man jemals braucht
Warum habe ich irgendwelche Container laufen?
Ne, habe ich gar nicht
Console-Only, GUI-Entwicklung Console-Only
Beste Idee, Max
Mono steht Spanisch für
Aha
So, ich mache mal kurz Updates
Von meinem System
Zack
Endcursus-GUI
Das ist auch outdated, overrated, jebaited
So, eine Runde mal updaten
Geht ja relativ schnell, dank
Arch-Linux, by the way
I use Arch
Ups
Ah, zu viel Themes
Ja, by the way
Nur mal nebenbei erwähnt
ZSH-deleted, okay
Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid
Arch-Linux
Oh, VSCode, neue Version
1.80
Was gibt es denn Neues?
Lass mal kurz, äh
Schnell mal rein
Was?
Ja
Was gibt's Neues?
Ist mir zu umfangreich, ich habe keinen Bock, das zu lesen
Image-Support im Terminal
Ach, haben sie es jetzt auch?
Ja, mein Terminal
Kam schon lange mit Image-Support
Das Visual Studio Code
Terminal hat jetzt Image-Support
Nice, aber es hat
Sixel-Support und Sixel
Suckt schon ziemlich
Es ist viel besser
Dass ich sogar
Nicht nur Image-Support, sondern ich habe sogar
GIF-Image-Support im Terminal
Nur mal so nebenbei erwähnt
Guck mal
Unendlich, ajaja
50%
CPU-Last
Okay, aber
Seht ihr hier?
Massive, massive
Bild-Support hier, GIF-Support
Ich mach das mal zu, das braucht bestimmt
800 MB RAM alleine jetzt
Okay, äh
Warte mal, System wurde geupdated
Ich hab
Packages geupdated, alles
Ich reboote mal schnell
An String erinnern
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, ich hab extra
Runde T hier stehen
Würdest du mit Java
Größere Apps programmieren?
Also ich persönlich, ne
Aber ja, man kann mit
Java ohne Probleme
Größere Anwendungen programmieren
Oder meinst du mit Apps Mobile-Anwendungen?
Mit Mobile-Anwendungen hast du es
Easy unter Android und nahezu
Unmöglich unter iOS
Wobei ich das nicht weiß
Ich würde nicht wundern, wenn es irgendwelche
Java-Sachen auch für iOS gibt, aber
Da gibt's besseres
Aber wenn du generell umfangreiche
Anwendungen meinst, da ist Java wahrscheinlich
Eines der
Erprobtesten Technologien, die es
Gibt, wenn es um große, umfangreiche
Business-Enterprise-Stonks-Anwendungen
Geht und selbst
Desktop-Anwendungen sollen mit Java ja ganz
Gut sein, mit dem
Es ist ja nicht mal Spring, was die jetzt haben
Wie heißt denn das neue JavaFX?
Wie kann das sein? Wie heißt das neue
Java-UI, was es seit ein paar Jahren
Gibt? Das ist doch
Auch ganz nice
Hab ich gehört
Wenn man eben auf Java-Sachen steht
Ja, ich kenn mich mit Java nicht aus
Java ist doch nicht
Langsam
Java ist performance-technisch echt nicht übel
Das Problem ist an Java, dass
Die Leute früher unglaublich
Viel RAM-Usage hatten, weil sie es nicht
Gebacken bekommen haben und der Startup ist
Mit Java halt oftmals lahm
Aber die Performance ist tatsächlich mit Java
Nicht schlecht
Okay, mit was macht man UIs in Java?
Was ist da zur Zeit
Angesagt?
Wer ist im Java-Game
Dabei?
Java-UI-Framework
Die sechs besten UI-Frameworks für Java
Oder Java, wie das die coolen Leute nennen
Ja
Spring
Wenn einer eine Anwendung haben will
Die aussieht wie 1992
Dann kann er das mit Spring machen
Aber Qt gibt es doch nicht mit Java
Oder gibt es das doch?
Grails kenn ich nicht
Hibernate
Hibernate ist doch kein UI-Framework
Hibernate ist doch ein Datenbank-Mapper
Oder? Warum steht denn das
Bei UI-Framework? Wollen die mich veräppeln?
Was ist das für eine total dämlich
Bescheuerte Liste
Chat-GPT-Artikel
Oder?
Trash
Komplett Trash
So, ich muss mal kurz
Meine Anwendung updaten
Avalonia-UI
Ich habe nämlich gelesen, dass die
Angeblich auch ein Rider-Plugin haben
Guckt mal da
JetPlanes Rider-Setup
Wir machen heute wirklich
Wieder letzte Kacknup, was übrigens auch bin
Was Avalonia angeht
Tatsächlich mal nach der offiziellen
Getting-Started-Anleitung
Machen wir das mal
Aber vorher müssen wir meine Anwendung noch updaten
Das ist aktuell wie die Pest
In jedem Forum
Oder auf jeder Seite
Gibt es nur noch Botspam
Youtube-Comments Botspam
Kommentarfunktionen auf irgendeinem
Botspam, Reddit
Versuchter Botspam, Foren Botspam
Home Assistant Community Botspam
Alles
Ich frag mich halt, was sie davon
Haben
Weil das macht ja nicht irgendwie Werbung
Für irgendwas, das sind einfach sinnlose
Okay, es gibt ein paar Scams auf Youtube
Die nicht unbedingt jetzt von
Chat-GPT-Artikeln
Geflutet werden, sondern es gibt
So Scams, so die
Üblichen Crypto-Scam-Comments, die habt ihr
Bestimmt auch schon gelesen auf Youtube
So nach dem Motto, ho, ich folge jetzt
Max-FPS auf Youtube, weil es ist der
Geilste Crypto-Dude
Und dann antwortet so ein Typ
Auf den Kommentaren, oh ja, Max-FPS
Krasser Crypto-Dude, dem folge ich auch
Schon lange, der hat richtig Plan
Und dann gibt es so eine 30
30-seitige
Konversation in den Kommentaren
Du weißt halt, dass es einfach nur noch sinnlose
Spam-Bots sind, die miteinander reden
Max-FPS hat seine Investitionen
Verdoppelt, genau sowas
Wobei ich echt sagen muss, also
Generell, ja
Der Datenaustausch, mir kann
Keiner erzählen, dass es da keinen Datenaustausch
Gibt, zwischen Amazon
Google
Facebook und sowas
Weil, also entweder war das einfach
Nur extrem kurzer
Zufall
Was auch sein kann, weil ich ja
Nicht der Einzige bin, der sowas sucht, aber
Zumindest letztens
Letztens ging es ja
In Russland richtig ab, so mit
Den Söldnern und alles, da habe ich ein bisschen gesucht
Bei Google sowas Neues zu dem Thema
Auf Twitter ein bisschen gelesen
Und auf einmal gehe ich bei Amazon Prime Video
Will mir noch ein paar Filme angucken
Was kriege ich empfohlen? Jagd auf roter Oktober
Oder irgendwelche russischen Filme
Irgendwelche russischen Sachen
Mit russischem Bezug
Das kann doch nicht sein
Dass ich einen Film von, keine Ahnung
1998 oder so empfohlen kriege
Random einfach, und vorher irgendwas
Nach Russland gesucht habe
Das ist doch, das kann doch nicht sein
Das ist doch
Das ist doch zu
Zu großer Zufall
Und auch letztens, auch wieder
Der Film ist tatsächlich nice, ja
Und
Letztens auch, ich hab
Ein Dienstleister gegoogelt
Der bei uns auf der Arbeit
Aktiv ist
Und dann gehe ich auf Twitter
Einen Tag danach, und dann empfiehlt
Mir Twitter, ich soll diesem Dienstleister
Dem Twitter-Account von diesem Dienstleister
Auf Twitter
Folgen, plus die zwei Gründer
Wurden mir auch noch direkt vorgeschlagen, zum Followen
Aber das kann doch nicht
Sein, dass das
Ist doch unmöglich, dass die das einfach
Erraten haben, die müssen sich doch
Da irgendwelche Daten austauschen
Ja, in dem Fall könnte das
Tatsächlich, könnte das so sein, ja
Ne
Hab ich nicht
Du kriegst Onlyfans-Spam?
Sag ich nicht, ich hab PMs aber auch überall aus
So
Also, wir haben alles geupdated
Oh Pog
Dann gucken wir uns doch mal die offizielle
Getting-Started-Anleitung an
Samples, Video, haben wir einen eigenen YouTube-Channel?
Äh
Nicht wirklich, oder?
AngelSix
Das hört sich an wie irgendwie
Aus Modern Warfare irgendwas
AngelSix
Going Dark
So, Installation, gucken wir uns das
Ganze nochmal an
Angel did it again
Angel does it again, oder
Ich weiß nicht, was er erzählt hat, aber
Cringe
Achso, wir sollten vielleicht mal bei der Gelegenheit nochmal einmal .NET
Aktualisieren
Ja, wir benutzen
Natürlich die 8er-Version, wenn überhaupt, dann schon
Bleeding-Edged as fuck
Warum sollten wir
Irgendwas Supportedes benutzen, wenn wir auch
Unsupportedes benutzen können
.NET Arch Preview 5
Was gibt's denn da eigentlich Neues
Das müssen wir auch mal kurz rein
Stelzen, hab ich nämlich überhaupt nicht
Mitgekriegt, dass das rausgekommen ist
Dabei kam das schon vor einem Monat
Raus, haben wir doch gar nicht geguckt, okay
Lass mal schnell checken
Enhancements to
Metric IPs
Das, ah okay
Juckt mich jetzt nicht
Sourcelink, was ist
Sourcelink
Dass man besser debuggen kann
Oder sowas
.NET Library Analyzers
Juckt mich jetzt
Auch nicht großartig
SDK Linux self-contained
Das ging doch die ganze Zeit schon, oder
Linux Distribution Build
SDK kann auch Build self-contained
Applicator that
Utilize source build
Runtime Packages
Ach, ähm
Das sind ihre Code-Generator-Dinger, oder
Vermutlich
Ja, alles nicht sonderlich spannend
Äh
War nicht wild, dass wir uns das nicht angeguckt haben
.NET
7 auf 8
Hä?
Ne, die Preview von 4 auf 5
Oder was? Oder wie? Hä?
Ist Git eigentlich useful?
Arbeitest du nicht bei Google?
Sollte das Google-Five-Header
nicht klar sein, ob Git useful ist oder nicht?
Ne Moment, das war jemand anderes
glaube ich
Ich glaube, das bringe ich jetzt durcheinander
Ähm, also natürlich ist Git useful
Es ist immer die Frage
Ob es sich lohnt
Für, sagen wir so
Irgendwas schnell zusammengewurscheltes
In, in, in
Mit 5 Zeilen
Was du einmalig machst und dann irgendwie
Nicht mehr verwendest, das irgendwie einzuchecken
Ins Git und so, muss man sich überlegen
Aber für alles, was ein bisschen länger Bestand hat
Ach ja, stimmt
Ja, da habe ich mich vertan
Also, für alles, was ein bisschen länger Bestand hat
Und wo du vielleicht auch
Zumindest schon eine Idee hast
Da könnte man auch was dran machen müssen
Ist es sinnvoll
Weil automatisch
Hast du dann auch ein Backup, wenn du es irgendwo hinpuschst
Ja, also ich finde das sinnvoll
Und vor allem, wenn du selbst mal nachgucken willst
Wie das vor ein paar Monaten ausgesehen hat
Als es noch ging
Oder wo du vermutest, dass es noch ging
Git hat einfach sehr viele praktische Sachen
Also ich finde, das lohnt sich
Wollt ihr es mit Eclipse nutzen? Nee, nee, nee, nee
Das ist auch ganz, ganz
Schlechte Idee
Also erstens sind zwei Sachen
Zwei Sachen sind
Eine schlechte Idee
Das erste ist Eclipse
Und das zweite ist, das Git-Eclipse-Plugin zu benutzen
Wobei du das zweite Problem nicht hast
Wenn du das erste Problem entsorgst
Aber allgemein würde ich sagen
Keine Git-Addons
Git-UIs
Und solche Geschichten
Benutz Git auf der Kommandozeile
Das ist einfach das Beste, was es gibt
Ich weiß, da bin ich
Nicht
Wie soll ich sagen
Es gibt noch mehr
Also es gibt noch andere, die haben da eine gegenteilige Meinung zu
Habe ich auch hier im Stream schon öfters gesehen
Die gesagt haben, ach doch, ich benutze das mit GUI
Alles viel geiler
Ich bin der Meinung, Git-Commandline ist das Beste, was es gibt
Bitestrike
Egregate auch
Ja, die Git-Integration
In Emacs ist beispielsweise auch ganz gut
Zur Zeit, in der ich auch Emacs verwendet habe
Aber trotzdem
Ich würde immer Git-Commandline vorziehen
Wie sind denn die
Commands
Ich checke mit Bash nichts
Das verstehe ich nicht
Die Git-Commands
Sind halt die Commands, die du brauchst
Um das zu machen, was du machen willst
Also
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen random Antwort
Aber woher soll ich wissen
Was du machen willst
Die Git-Man-Pages
Sind halt ein bisschen pp-iger
Ich sage nur, habe ich euch schon 500 mal als Beispiel gebracht
Die Man-Pages versteht immer niemand
Ich sehe hier
Einen ehemaligen Emacs-Enjoyer
Wie resolvt man Konflikte
Ohne UI
Du machst einen Editor raus
Du machst einen Editor auf
Du stellst die Teile raus, die du nicht haben willst
Weil du die mit Markern angezeigt kriegst
Und dann addest du es und
Committest es oder machst dann Rebase weiter
Oder sagst dann Cherry Pick, Continue, Merge, Continue
Das ist nicht schwierig
Wenn es ein bisschen komplizierter wird
Weil es ein bisschen länger und ein bisschen größer ist
Und es viele Merge-Konflikte gibt in den Files
Dann ist tatsächlich ein UI
Zum Mergen ganz praktisch
Übrigens, ich zeige euch mal ein mega-nices Tool
Und zwar
Habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit vermehrt benutzt
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin ziemlicher
Purist, was
Git-CLI angeht
Ähm
Haben wir hier ein Git-Repo gemacht?
Was ist das nochmal?
Hatten wir nicht letztens so ein
Na egal
Na gut, ich weiß nicht was das ist
Aber da gehen wir mal rein
Ich zeige euch mal was, und zwar das hier
Das ist Megapog, das habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit
Öfters verwendet
Und zwar ist das
Eine bessere Diff-Anzeige
Für Command-Line-Tools
Also normalerweise sieht eine Diff-Anzeige
So aus
So
Okay, ist auch ganz nice
Ja, aber das geht besser
Zum Beispiel, wenn man
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man Delta übers Aure
Installieren kann, doch kann man
Ne, doch hier
Rust, by the way
Wie sage ich
Die offizielle Install-Anleitung
Ja
Ach, wusste ich doch
Ich wollte gerade sagen
Kann mich nicht dran erinnern
Okay, genau
Und jetzt kann man hier beispielsweise
So was machen, da
Pager, Delta, Diff
Delta und sonst was
Und
Na gut, eigentlich ist nur das das interessante
Ich kopiere das
Einfach mal rein, zumindest zeige ich euch mal
Der Unterschied
Okay, da ist schon Zeug drin
Und jetzt, Log
Guck mal da
Ist das nicht ein viel
Niceres Diff
Ist doch viel besser
Viel besser, was denn
Wieder hinzugekommen ist
Ja, das Standard-Farbschema passt vielleicht nicht so gut
Zu meinem Terminal
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut
Aber ich werde es jetzt erstmal
Wieder
Wieder entsorgen
Jetzt sieht es wieder normal aus
Okay
Also, was haben wir sonst noch
Man braucht zum reinen Benutzen tatsächlich
Nicht so viel, ja
Aber es ist schon sinnvoll auch ein bisschen links und rechts was zu kennen
Zum Beispiel wie man was resettet
Wie man Sachen
Anhängt
Wie man
Seinen Feature-Branch rebased
Wie man ein Stash benutzt
Also ein paar Sachen sind schon ganz nützlich
Um rum zu wissen
Aber prinzipiell braucht man gar nicht so viel, das stimmt schon
Ich auch
Ja, wenn
Wenn du gerade anfängst und hauptsächlich
Eclipse benutzt, mach das
Sprich dir eigentlich nichts dagegen
Ich muss aber sagen, mir persönlich wäre
Wenn ich Java machen würde
Ich würde übrigens gar kein Java mehr machen
Ich würde Kotlin machen, aber das ist was anderes
Ich würde wahrscheinlich IntelliJ benutzen, das ist auch kostenlos
Und
Die haben für alles ziemlich gute Ideen
Aber Eclipse geht genauso gut
Ja, ich auch
Ich würde das auch empfehlen
Twitch-Logik
Ist das Autovervollständigung in der Bash?
Ich weiß nicht auf was du dich beziehst, aber ja
Das meiste wird bei mir autovervollständigt
So, okay
IntelliJ ist kostenlos, ja guck
Also die Ultimate-Version kostet was
Aber die Community Edition ist kostenlos
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was die Unterschiede sind
Zwischen Community Edition und
Ultimate
Wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit Plugins oder so
Vielleicht wisst ihr es, ich hab keine Ahnung
Wir können mal kurz gucken
IntelliJ
Community vs
Ultimate
Hat keinen Typescript-Support
Ja, das wird die meisten doch eh nicht jucken
Okay, also
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Community
Edition und Ultimate
Okay, es gibt ein paar
Programmiersprachen, Addons nicht
Vollkommen irrelevant, man möchte ja eigentlich
Java machen oder Kotlin
Was man
Oder vielleicht KUBI
Was man ja auch ohne Probleme machen kann
Es werden ein paar zusätzliche
Feilformate nicht direkt unterstützt, das ist aber auch
überhaupt kein Problem aus meiner Sicht
So
Gut, du hast ein bisschen weniger Support für manche
Frameworks
Springboot
Blah und sonst, aber das ist jetzt auch
Okay, sie haben anscheinend
Integration von irgendwelchen Datenbanken
Mappern, aber das ist jetzt nichts
Wo ich sagen würde, oh ja, das braucht man unbedingt
Und gerade wenn man startet, nicht
Was ist GWT
Leute, Chatge?
Ich kenn mich mit Java nicht aus
Also ich würde sagen, du kommst wunderbar klar auch mit
der Community Edition
Profiling-Tools sind nicht dabei, okay
Database-Tools sind
nicht dabei
Also ganz ehrlich, damit kann man
ohne Probleme arbeiten, würde ich sagen
Das ist
so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich die gleiche Frage
Wie ob PyCharm Community
Versus PyCharm Professional
Ich meine, ich habe
PyCharm Professional und den ganzen anderen Krempel installiert
Weil ich habe ja so eine
All-Desktop-Package
gekauft von denen
Aber du kannst auch die kostenlosen
Sachen benutzen
Also ich kann es euch nur empfehlen
Das Jetbrain-Zeug ist wirklich gut
Und wenn man das professionell benutzt
Lohnt sich dafür auch
das Geld auszugeben für so einen
Für dieses Ultimate
IDE-Bundle
Eventuell, wenn ich es auf der Arbeit brauche
bezahlt da sogar euer Arbeitgeber
Wäre ja auch möglich
Das ist schon okay
Wenn du eine Tutorial-Serie machst
Von einem, der auch hauptsächlich
Eclipse benutzt und da Sachen zeigt
Macht es durchaus Sinn
Vielleicht im Tutorial-Eclipse
Da auch zu bleiben
Wobei ich persönlich sagen muss
Ich mache um Eclipse einen ganz großen Bogen
Ich fange nächsten Monat eine Ausbildung zum Physi an
Sollte ich
mir vorher schon anschauen, was genau IP-Vorf...
Oder ich lerne hier alles von Grund auf
Interesse ist enorm
Ja dann, mach, leg los
Es ist durchaus sinnvoll, dir im Vorfeld schon
Sachen anzugucken
Gerade was Basics angeht, ist nicht verkehrt
Du könntest ja auch mal
die ein oder andere Linux-Distribution
in AVM installieren
Ich meine, wenn du Bock drauf hast, mach doch
Es wird dir auf jeden Fall nicht schaden
Das ist ein Abo-Modell
Aber es ist relativ erträglich
JetPrints
All
Products Pack
Lasst euch mal
nicht gebeten von dem Preis, der gleich
da steht, weil das ist für Organizations
For Individual
Use
Kostet dich hier
Das All Products Pack
Kostet dich
173 Dollar ab dem dritten Jahr
Also mit
Mehrwertsteuer 205 Euro
Nicht Dollar, Euro
Ja, es ist ein Abo, aber ehrlich
Jetzt mal ernsthaft
Wenn man es wirklich professionell benutzt
Und damit was
macht, wie sagt man so schön
Wertschöpfung
Oder wie auch immer man das nennen will
Dann sind
im Jahr
205 Dollar
205 Euro
Wirklich in Ordnung
Abo ist nervig, das stimmt
Aber du kriegst halt auch immer Updates
Das ist auch in Ordnung
Ich muss sagen, ich bin auch kein Abo-Fan
Aber das ist
wirklich was, was sich geldmäßig
meiner Meinung nach lohnt
Gerade wenn man damit sein Geld verdient
Also wenn du Git-Probleme mit Eclipse hast
Mach Git auf der Kommando-Seite
Das ist einfach zum Lernen
Nachvollziehbarer
Das kann ich mir vorstellen
Rider-Desktop-Entwicklung, wir probieren das heute aus
Übrigens, aber Rider-Desktop-Entwicklung
Was Windows Forms und WPF angeht
Und sowas, ja, ich glaube
Das funktioniert nicht, das habe ich aber auch noch nie probiert
Und ich habe auch nicht das Verlangen danach
Ehrlich gesagt
Bei welchen Sprachen würdest du JetBrains gegenüber
Visual Studio Code bevorzugen?
Go?
C-Sharp?
Wahrscheinlich auch Python, mache ich aber nicht so viel mit
Für
Web-Frontend-Gedöns
bevorzuge ich tatsächlich Visual Studio Code
Für C
und C++
In Kombination für Microcontroller
mit Plattform-IO bevorzuge ich
tatsächlich auch Visual Studio Code
Wobei Plattform-IO auch
mit anderen IDEs funktioniert
Ruby?
Tatsächlich beste, falls noch irgendjemand
Ruby macht, RubyMine ist nice
Java mache ich nicht
Für alles andere
Visual Studio Code
Oder NeoVim, wie die coolen Leute
das heute machen
Was benutzt du für Rust?
Was haben wir für Rust
benutzt? Ich glaube auch Visual Studio Code
Ne, das IntelliJ
Rust-Plugin haben wir glaube ich dafür benutzt
das letzte Mal
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr genau
Schon eine Weile her
Und ich bin auch nicht so scharf drauf
großartig Rust zu machen
Hehehe
Womit du am besten anfängst?
Naja, nachdem du noch wenig Vorkenntnisse hast
würde ich sagen das, was dich am meisten interessiert
Ja, ist schon ein bisschen
weirdchamp, das stimmt mit den ganzen
Subs überall
Das gefällt dir aber erst besser, bis du irgendwas mit C
interop machen musst
Das letzte Mal, wo ich Go und C
interop machen musste, ist das Visual Studio
Plugin bei C
Go regelmäßig gecrashed und dann ging gar
nichts mehr, kein Intellisense und nix
Vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile gefixt
Ja, das klingt doch sinnvoll
Ok, also, lass uns
nochmal, guck mal, es gibt sogar ein Rider Setup
Ist das direkt bei
Getting Started drin gewesen? Installation
Ne
Ist es nicht
Also
.NET CLI, Installation
.NET New Install Avalonia
Templates
Wir machen mal ein neues Repo, mkdir
Das ist ja eine globale Installation
So, was haben wir jetzt für
Templates? Da ist ein
Rider Button
Ach da, guck mal da
JetBrains Rider IDE has built-in support
for Avalonia XAML
Starting in 2... jetzt hab ich
Including first class support for Avalonia
Specific XAML
XAML features
and custom code inspections
Live
Previewing of Avalonia XAML
Files
Installed for Never
Heißt der wirklich so, oder ist es ein Künstlername?
Der kann auch nicht wirklich so heißen. Oder?
Das
ist einfach viel zu Elite,
der Name
Ok, Avalonia Rider, dann installieren
wir das doch grad mal, wenn wir schon dabei sind
Install Friedrich von
Never, das hört sich an
wie ein Dungeons and Dragons
Charakter
No, god!
JavaFX
okay also wie geht das jetzt also ich muss sagen dass getting started ist doch recht minimalistisch
oder is getting started ja okay hier gibt es hier gibt es eine ordentliche anleitung jetzt
startet install ja gut dann legen wir doch mal eine app an ok.net new list avalonia avalonia.net
app avalonia mvvm das ist doch die das ist die wpf geschichte das ist model view view
model okay das machen wir nicht code behind datei beste wir fangen heute nicht an irgendwie
mit clean architecture und so zeug avalonia cross platform application xplot was ist der
unterschied zwischen einer .net app und einer cross platform application ach mobile mobile
nee desktop avalonia web mobile und und und das hier ist ohne ohne web oder wie okay set up an
editor jetbrains rider ja das haben wir schon gemacht introduction create and run a project
okay na dann let's go .net run okay dann starten wir es gleich können wir gleich mal gucken ob
das unter linux funktioniert ordentlich .net run ach so ich habe es nicht richtig gestartet
was framework 6 okay das muss ich um das muss ich umschalten mit framework 6 mal ganz davon
abgesehen ich will es auch ich will ich will es auch hier hiermit starten ich will es mit .net
8 .net 8 starten rider wir müssen das in rider aufmachen und die .net version umstellen was
willst du von mir okay trust wir trusten alles getrusted schon mal f sharp benutzt nein okay
hier haben wir zeug hier haben wir eine preview angeblich kann man es previewen habe ich gehört
wir müssen jetzt erst noch mal umstellen die .net version und zwar wollen wir .net 8 haben
wie kam angeblich kann man sich die die sachen ja previewen lassen in spec code oben rechts
da kann man starten aber nicht das was ich haben will und am start da ist nix was chat
wollt ihr mich verarschen links neben der datenbank das da ach ok da passiert nix ach
so aber mein projekt ok das projekt geht noch nicht das projekt ist eingestellt auf was ja
target framework 8 c sharp 11 so können wir jetzt previewen no build output detected ja
ok dann bilden wir das ganze mal jetzt habe ich meinen editor zu gemacht sehr schlau max
jetzt war rider direkt direkt problem main window ich weiß nicht genau wo das problem
ist aber war es einfach .net run wir haben ein fenster welcome to avalonia mit ziemlich
mit ziemlich miesem font rendering würde ich sagen aber geht schon halbwegs so und
jetzt habe ich habe ich jetzt preview jetzt ok das muss einmal so bilden ok das ist schon mal
nice dass man in preview hat ok ist das reload das live wenn ich hier misst oh guck mal da
web 5.0 experience die frage ist ob das auch mit anderen sachen funktioniert so keine ahnung ja
was können wir denn da einfügen ich weiß überhaupt nicht was für start button button
gibt es gibt überall buttons beim brocken aber wahrscheinlich weil man nur ein übergeordnetes
element haben dafür content is set more than once ich erinnere mich mit grauen an meine
wpf geschichten da gab es doch so stack panel und sowas früher kecke haben wir den button
aber einfachen text geht nicht oder was text ist not expected hier text das funktioniert
ok sehr schön massive massive text haben wir hier am start ok da machen wir mal einen button
click me ja ja ok ganz toll und jetzt starten wir das und gucken ob das funktioniert exzellent
das ist ein bisschen kaputt aber aber in ordnung in ordnung schon schon mal gut ok
also wir machen jetzt eine eine super simple app so also die die sein wird die seinheit das ist
doch eigentlich egal auch für mein programm oder kann ich dann kann ich da nicht das ist nur für
den nur für den designer ich wollte halt eigentlich so klein machen so klein machen wie wie möglich
die app so quasi weil sie sodass hat nicht kleiner geht so ok wie kann man da jetzt ok jetzt kommt
jetzt kommt es euch da habe ich gar keine ahnung von wir brauchen wir brauchen ein bild image
image wir gucken gleich mal ob das ding ob das den gift anzeigen kann da bin ich mal gespannt
source wenn ich das noch richtig erinnert habe ok anders das geht nicht ok kann man nicht aus dem
projekt rausgehen ok dann cp download anime exited gift ganz wichtig da ist es doch expected
build action avalonia resource aus ist brauchen oder resource not found so wie mache ich das
jetzt wie mache ich das jetzt zu einer avalonia resource properties build action avalonia resource
ok das funktioniert aber es ist kein gift aber es ist es ist schon mal es ist kein gift es wird
aber ordentlich es wird aber ordentlich resized ja das ist schon mal was ordentlich ordentlich
wird seitenverhältnis richtig ist dass das funktioniert schon mal ok die die große die
große preisfrage ist jetzt den textblock machen wir weg aber lonja image gift kann das gift
animation gift renderer and player nee das ist ein third party projekt das ist das kann er nicht
ich habe jetzt gehofft dass das eigentliche image element kann das kann man es hier sagen
breite 100 pixel nicht pixel einfach nur 100 höher 20 das sind immer das kleinste und das
seitenverhältnis kann man auch sagen es weckt nee was hat man denn hier für sachen zu außer ich
bin halt so abzuplanen was was xaml angeht nein also klipp stretch hier dann ist egal aber das
funktioniert trotzdem nicht oder weil das seitenverhältnis bleibt immer noch gleich
nicht wirklich keine ahnung naja das ist jetzt auch erst mal nicht so wild weil wir machen jetzt
die die beste anwendung überhaupt wenn man auf den button klickt dann wird das bild angezeigt
und wenn man wieder auf den button klickt dann wird das bild versteckt das muss erst mal reichen
ja so wie wie alleine ich das jetzt überhaupt centert mit dem stack panel wahrscheinlich gar
nicht allein allein center so einfach das glaube jetzt aber nicht wie jetzt das geht jetzt einfach
schon ist schon ist der button in der mitte fasse es nicht okay so und wir machen jetzt ein klick
klick okay button on click so code behind beste so und wenn mich jetzt meine wpf
kenntnisse nicht verlassen haben dann muss man jetzt irgendwie sowas machen wie x name image
okay image meinetwegen und jetzt kann ich hier mit image drauf zugreifen genau image
sons wie heißt das also wir geben jetzt die sons nicht hier an wir machen die sons jetzt
hier wieder weg und setzen die sons hier so einfach ging das ja das war wpf da ist
sind alle sachen nicht einfach mit map keine ahnung teilnehmen okay ob das wird das wird
dann nicht checken oder hier probieren wir mal aus tatsächlich funktioniert
nein so okay private wohl kecke gleich falls beste beste benahmung überhaupt so
ansonsten image so ich meine wir könnten das auch inline schreiben eigentlich müssen wir
übrigens warum habe ich so viel abstand dazwischen ich will doch eigentlich nur zwei
formats also viel besser falls ist ansonsten you bitmap empty gibt es sowas wie empty ja
wie setze ich ein leeren auf null auf null einfach setzen oder okay ich setze das ja auch
gar nicht ich bin ja blöd dann muss ich das doch mit machen wir nennen das ding mal ordentlich
show image if not show image dann das da und wir setzen stimmt das hätte ich auch machen können ja
so und das hier auf null ihr habt recht die beste die bessere variante wäre tatsächlich gewesen so
und das andere dann ja wenn show image gesetzt ist jetzt hier so wenn wenn show
image gesetzt ist dann das ansonsten null okay dann huge beste app überhaupt jetzt
gleich hops hops genommen ja okay background color background komm mal da kann man kann man
sowas hier machen tatsächlich uns aber aber aber es zeigt nichts richtig an doch moment warum hat
mein button background color vom window was ist das muss ich dem stack panel background geben oder
ist der transparent mein button ich brauche irgendwas was nicht nicht ganz so in den augen
weh tut wenn man es aufmacht ja das ganz toll button background muss man dann extra background
setzen dass der das nicht aha ah ja okay verstehe also sprich okay es funktioniert
beste app überhaupt ich würde sagen nächster innovationspreis ist uns was du sehend bist
die neue price winning app up and coming oder up and running ne wie heißt das die kommende
neue top rated app okay jetzt können wir mal eine sache ausprobieren die mich wirklich sehr
interessiert und zwar wie macht man das jetzt cross platform also unter linux funktioniert
ja schon mal aber wie kann ich das jetzt bilden und einfach so zu wenden auf windows ausführen
das müssen wir jetzt rauskriegen muss man für hover auch ein background definieren du meinst
wenn man über den du meinst wenn man über den button geht dass es dann irgendwie hover anzeigt
ja anscheinend kann man anscheinend kann man für den button noch hover irgendwie definieren aber ich
weiß nicht wie aber lohnt ja button hover color oh jetzt wird es aber langsam advanced das macht
man in xml eigentlich mit triggern und styles meine xml ist jetzt jahrzehnte kann man in über
zehn jahre her was wpf und sowas angeht ich habe keine ahnung mehr okay dann gucken wir gucken wir
einfach xml button hover color das geht how do we change a background for button mouse over in
wpf das kann es das kann doch so nicht sein oder ja so schlau bin ich auch dass man im background
color setzen kann das doch wir wie zum was ich ich blick's nicht okay ich blicke überhaupt nicht
was sie mir überhaupt sagen wollen ehrlich gesagt button rest fly out open was ich verstehe
überhaupt nicht was sie was sie wissen die wissen wollen okay avalonia hover color so wir gucken
jetzt hier wir gucken jetzt hier in die in die cash version weil reddit wiederum spack okay wpf
wir holen wir holen das wpf example was zum was ist das für eine ausgeburt der hölle für ein
für eine hover color das ist doch nicht euer ernst oder style okay also style selector button
doppelpunkt war das ist bleibt press nee das war gar nicht kontert ist jetzt aber
man das war button style was man machen muss geboten button punkt styles musste man machen
und dann style innen drin style ah ja ah ja ok ok und jetzt wenn der button press ok das
funktioniert ok ok prinzipiell funktioniert es prinzipiell jetzt ok aber ich will ja gar
nicht von zeit ich will ja eigentlich eigentlich will ich ja setter property background auf sagen
wir mal jetzt keine ahnung yellow so dass man zwingend erkennt und ich funktioniert
okay das mit das funktioniert so nicht red nee wie zum teufel mache ich den button background
red pointer over image der fuck die meinte sind image styles template content presenter
was funktioniert so nicht vor allem warum gibt es es gibt ja nicht mal intelligenz für es gibt
nur ist not pressed fly out open das template dahinter ist wichtig welches template das da was
was heißt das überhaupt ich kopiere das jetzt einfach ich weiß wirklich nicht was es macht
aber ich kopiere das jetzt einfach ok es geht ich habe absolut gar keine ahnung warum das
funktioniert obviously obviously komplett selbsterklärend easy kann man das blöde ist
es gibt keinen intelligenz dafür ich weiß überhaupt nicht was ich ok template template
intelligenz er schon mal content presenter geht auch leute wirklich ich ich weiß nur was es
bedeuten soll aber es funktioniert ne ne das bleibt nicht rot es bleibt nur rot weil ich weil
weil er das hier nicht checkt mit dem wenn ich mit der mit dem aus raus gehe ich gehe davon aus in
der echten anwendung ist das kein problem guckt da checkt er das ok als heißt so jetzt ist dahinter
kann bot jetzt machen wir den foreground den fog vor foreground den machen wir jetzt weit dass man
noch ordentlich was erkennt so und jetzt gehe ich da drüber und ok ok das schon mal da schon mal
nice so beste die geilste app überhaupt gut wie bilde ich das ganze denn jetzt cross platform ich
glaube das ist der typische fall von wenn man irgendwas neu macht wahrscheinlich ergibt das
hier irgendwie sinn wenn man es mal kapiert hat ich habe es einfach noch nicht kapiert was ich
halt nicht verstehe ist warum das hier kein intelligenz gibt ich mein warum zum teufel muss
man wissen dass es point over heißt pointer over kann man doch gar nicht wissen ok run projekts
main window add control layouts input control ich will ich will wissen wie man das bildet
aber lohnt ja bild ich aber lohnt aber lohnt ja windows das ist wie man das dafür
publisch app distribution und publishing ok nice publish running on a raspberry pi ok das heißt
man muss eigentlich ok platforms android ios wie wäre es wie wäre es mit linux und windows als
beispiel so das sind die sachen die man braucht publisch ich mein aber lohnt ja publisch windows
app how to deploy ja genau simply.net publish works perfectly fine don't net publish minus c
release minus f ja das braucht man nicht minus r hier linux linux x64 self-contained was ach
moment ja muss man auch richtig im .net .net nicht docker .net so und das oder soll jetzt einfach so
funktionieren bin release das sieht aber nicht sonderlich self-contained aus wenn ich ehrlich
bin war dann das jetzt published hier release publisch moment self-contained allein reicht
ja nicht man muss ja single .net publisch wie war das noch mal nicht self-contained das .net
self-contained single single executable muss man doch angeben publisch single file true ja das
musste man machen ok das das war das ja ich erinnere mich publisch das muss weg das muss
hin und minus o einfach in bildordner easy so jetzt aber cd bild und da haben wir eine
getting started app zack liegt es an meiner ressource dass er nicht weiß wo das bild
herkommt ich dachte ich habe das embedded das bild habe ich das bild nicht embedded
ich musste das doch explizit explizit auf ich muss es doch explizit auf ressource setzen copy
to output directory ja geil avalon ja embed images das ist komplizierter als ich das vorgestellt
habe was jeder hat es ja gar nicht kopiert da das gar nicht ich hätte eigentlich gesagt mit
avalon ja ressource ich will es ja nicht ins output directory kopieren er soll es ja embedden
natürlich kann ich sagen hier bild mir das ganze mal aber das ist ja nicht sinn und zweck der
sache das bringt ja so nix guck jetzt hat er das bild hier rein kopiert noch nicht mal das
gar nichts gemacht hat er so funktioniert das nicht du not copy will man mal bild
ressource aus ich vermute dass das nicht funktionieren wird ja genau dann stimmt
der fahrt ja moment ich muss dem noch jetzt sagen dass der dass der irgendwelche embedded
ressourcen nehmen soll keine ahnung wie das funktioniert aber so schon mal nett
avalon ja image embedded wie funktioniert das assets many applications included assets such
as bitmaps ja das brauche ich okay including assets assets can be included in application
by using avalon ja ressource item in your project file ja mache ich das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht
slash assets muss man da vormachen okay probieren wir das mal aus also das habe ich ja schon gemacht
man muss das ding einfach auf avalon ja ressource stellen habe ich gemacht alles gut so und jetzt
will ich wo ist wo ist mein code dafür da assets run addox version ist zu alt keiner ist das
funktioniert schon mal nicht ja das gibt es doch nicht es wird sich wahrscheinlich nicht so viel
geändert haben drin okay dann gehen wir mal hier auf source gucken ob das ob das wenigstens
funktionieren würde wenn wir es von hand setzen source not found ja wie not found not found ach
so die haben das in assets gelegt ja aber gut dann war das doch eigentlich dann war das doch
vollkommen okay wie ich das gemacht habe da war das doch vollkommen okay ich habe das gesetzt auf
avalon ja ressource da war das doch richtig wie ich es gemacht habe leider leider funktioniert
das nicht doch ist es angeblich schon ja aber das kann doch das kann doch nicht so kompliziert
sein was reference manifest ist assets can also be included in .net applications by using the
embedded resource you can reference manifest resource using the resume jetzt jetzt wird es
advanced hier die resume starting with avalon elf doesn't support man use avalon ja resource
resource in seed avares also ach so geht das okay also aha aha avares getting started app
excited gif okay viel besser ja okay die frage ist okay ich lasse es erst mal so an der stelle
da sehen wir nämlich aufs prinzipiell funktioniert wir removen den bild folder
minus output bild im bildordner get started app ja schon viel besser okay das hat funktioniert
das heißt dann schnappen wir uns mal das hier gucken ob das auch noch funktioniert wenn man
das dynamisch setzt als bitmap ich hoffe ich hoffe ja mal ob das das checkt weil ich nicht
m so chat meinte es funktioniert ja oder nein crash das jetzt wenn ich auf den button klick
oder nicht ein von der idee müsste es passen aber wahrscheinlich check bitmap das ganze nicht
was mein dir crash oder kein crash das geht okay not found kannst du nicht das image aus doch doch
doch doch doch doch man könnte man könnte das sicherlich aber das geht bestimmt das image
einfach ausblenden und das initial aber muss es ja auch programmatisch irgendwie setzen können
image source new image image source ich erinnere mich wenn wpf gab es so was wie
image source die nur die gibt es nicht aber lohnt ja image source source ja man kann ja
kein string da übergeben das mag der ja nicht das darf das darf man nicht so aus property also
wpf war auch schon immer äußerst 6 hat kann man vielleicht ein bitmap ja nie das funktioniert an
der stelle nicht gibt es eine bitmap source ne gibt es auch nicht from resource was hier
wo war vor resource wo denn bitmap nee das ist irgendein windows zeug nee das funktioniert nicht
das ist das ist irgendein windows das ist irgendein legacy windows zeug in pointer zu
irgendwas nee nee so wir gucken mal in die docs kommen wir sind wir sind mal so nett
wir gucken in die docs rein da steht auch bestimmt irgendwas was ist das was ist was
ist das für eine ausgeburt der hölle wieder gibt es gibt es new uri oder so ja aber es
gibt doch schon einen fertigen converter must be done using using a binding converter
that will convert string to an image ja aber welchen welchen denn converter uri type converter
bitconverter brushconverter uri typeconverter okay wie kriege ich den string da rein nervt
mich nicht aber warum brauche ich so einen langen block wieder ich war ich meine er kann den krempel
ja konverten wenn ich es direkt auf dem image control setze dann funktioniert warum kann ich
das nicht einfach an der stelle das leuchtet mir nicht ein ich kann es so aus direkt setzen und
die wird konvertiert aber wenn ich direkt setzen will brauche ich irgendwie so ein ewig langes
ding was bitmap asset moment das ist da eingebaut bitmap in der gibt es überhaupt nicht ja okay
return you bitmap asset avalonia locator current gets avalonia locator current gibt es nicht
ja moment das ist ja auch für ja für version 11 gibt es das noch nicht controls image asset
loader asset loader heißt das ding jetzt einfach aha okay nice okay jetzt jetzt weiß ich wie es
geht so wie ist das ding hier aber es da muss da muss erst mal drauf kommen was wirklich string
ist overrated das geht nicht so asset gleich so nee nee nee moment new bitmap ist das jetzt was
anderes was das dafür blödsinn okay jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob es funktioniert jetzt jetzt
würde ich jetzt würde ich erwarten dass es geht wir können mal ran machen aha nice
bild jetzt startet app aber er löscht nicht mehr warum löscht das nicht mehr weil ich
ein blödsinn gebaut habe ja ich setze es immer hier drauf ja okay da ist sehr schlau max ja
okay show image ansonsten 0 okay jetzt aber gefixt also so jetzt haben wir ein linux
bild das funktioniert so richtig so richtig stand alone ist die app aber auch nicht oder
ja stimmt stimmt stimmt ziemlich ist ziemlich ist memory leak sogar weil wir
wobei es ist die frage ist das wirklich ein memory leak ich meine das hat keine referenz
mehr im garbage collector dann sollte eigentlich aufgeräumt werden das dürfte eigentlich kein
memory leak geben vermutlich vermutlich naja zumindest so ganz stand alone ist der kreml
ja auch nicht weil man braucht immer noch diese komischen dinger hier die auch schon einiges
einiges an größe haben ja so ganz stand alone ist es nicht weil weil ich gehe davon aus wenn
ich den kreml lösche na klar da ist kaputt okay dann probieren wir es trotzdem mal aus ob der
kram unter windows auch funktioniert also release linux wir wollen windows x64 haben jawohl dann
track und drop ich nehme das mal rüber auf windows und dann schauen wir mal so ich meine
das sollte jetzt nicht funktionieren nein ich meine wir können es mit wine ausführen wollen
wir das mal mit wine ausführen und gucken ob es funktioniert just for fun aber ich muss ich
muss ich muss ein snapshot machen das will ich das will ich wieder rückgängig machen wine
was ist das richtige von überhaupt inszeniert man wine unter arch dann weinst du inszeniert
multi lip repository oder wine stable wine stable was zum was das ist mir neu zwar gut
dass ich in snapshot gemacht habe ok multich soll multilip enable mache ich das doch mal
pack man ich weiß gar nicht wie ich multilip überhaupt in der über wenn ich ehrlich bin
ja schein pack man multilip multilip enabling multilip ok ja etc pack man konf multilip
ach so einfach hier das da easy und jetzt wahrscheinlich einmal abdehnen so jetzt
gibt es wahrscheinlich wine auch so da multilip wine auf geht's gut dass ich
ein snapshot gemacht habe i love candy ne habe ich nicht an normale progressbar sind
auch nicht verkehrt wine am start wine cfg ok das funst jawohl mono gib ihm wobei ich
brauche kein mono das ist self-contained anwendung egal mono installing mono alles
klar ok jetzt gibt es eigentlich eine gescheite software um ein backup unter
linux zu machen ja gibt es einige also das ist ganz gut wenn auch ein bisschen ein bisschen
lernen kurve das ist ganz nice kannst du aber auch eher clone verwenden um offseite backups
zu machen oder ansonsten wenn du sonst nichts machen willst einfach er sink genau ja wenn du
einfach nur was kopieren willst uns und synchron halten willst vom stand her also von a nach b und
immer updaten willst er sink wenn du was mit encryption für offseite backups und so was
brauchst dann aber schon ein bisschen mehr so jetzt gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert wine
get started app.exe das wäre jetzt ja auch zu einfach wenn das einfach gestartet hätte oder
mal gucken ob das überhaupt unter windows startet wir kopieren das jetzt wir kopieren das jetzt
mal rüber download du brauchst wine ne ne ne das ist eine self-contained .net app da ist .net
embedded drin pause champ pause champ warum auch immer da einen download ordner aufgegangen ist
er schließt sich mir nicht aber ich habe einen button ohne ohne text aber mir ist nicht ganz
klar warum eine konsole aufgeht aber es funktioniert wie ist Avalonia im vergleich
zu Xamarin der ansatz ist komplett anders warum ist der button übrigens unter windows fail color
und unter linux nicht also der grundsätzliche unterschied ist da bist du ja wieder also der
grundsätzliche unterschied ist Xamarin baut auf zumindest soweit ich das so weit ich das gelesen
habe also Xamarin beziehungsweise Maui ist ja das neue variante davon die verfolgen die taktik
dass sie die native controls von den jeweiligen plattformen nehmen also entweder wpf beziehungsweise
wpf uwp unter windows oder frag mich nicht was die alles unter windows unterstützen experimentellen
support mit gtk unter linux und Cocoa heißt das glaube ich unter unter mac os also sie benutzen
die native client die native libraries dafür und die native controls Avalonia malt alle
controls selbst was ich persönlich auch viel cooler finde weil dann sieht die app wenigstens
überall gleich aus wenn auch nicht super windows like aber sie sieht überall gleich aus
Leute warum kriege ich da irgendwie ein Fenster das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn warum startet
ein Fenster anstatt einfach die Anwendung das ist das ist bestimmt irgendein irgendein fail
ich hätte einen Kommandozeilen Parameter oder so ein Bild Parameter angeben müssen dass das
nicht so wäre ok also man muss ihnen aber schon mal eins zugute halten die app funktioniert sowohl
unter windows als auch unter linux gleich außer das mit dem button das ist irgendwie ein bisschen
kaputt die machen das wohl auch mit xia sieht man hier was ein bisschen doof ist dass es da
nicht komplett embedded ist ja es gibt mit Avalonia anscheinend noch keine kompletten
single file deployments da muss man immer noch irgendwas drumherum rappen ja auf mac würde
vermutlich auch funktionieren genau so wir stellen jetzt noch mal eine sache ein wir stellen es noch
mal eine sache ein und zwar bei bei den button dass der foreground standardmäßig black ist wenn
du den mac bild irgendwo hochlädt ach was brauchen wir nicht mit include native libraries
for self extrakt kannst du native oh jetzt wird es aber advanced mit mit was ist das
in Avalonia geschichte um diese dateien für die extrahierung einzubetten und eine ausgabe
natural legen sie die eigenschaft wie einfach als compile Parameter oder so und das war es dann
wird einfach so ich löscht den output folger noch mal wie jetzt mal gucken ob es jetzt mit
wine geht natürlich nicht wenn das funktioniert wäre schon sehr nice funktioniert ich bin
begeistert easy das erste mal dauert das start ein bisschen aber danach geht es das ist gar
nicht schlecht das ist wirklich nicht übel ich meine an die ganzen xml und wpf geschichten muss
man oder diese wpf style sachen muss man sich vielleicht ein bisschen gewöhnen aber nicht
schlecht ja es ist okay wo gibt es in den bild button leute wo ist in rider ein bild button ich
mache das immer über die kommandozeile wo ist der bild button das ist das start button gibt
es auch einfach ein bild button das da ist das nämlich auch nicht mehr brauchen weil wir mal
gebildet haben okay das ist das ist aber wirklich sehr nice das gefällt mir das das hat echt was
jetzt was ich mich jetzt noch frage ist aber lohnt ja windows console window warum macht
man das so einen komischen console window ja wo ist das problem ach so guck mal wenn
i build and run the app on windows console window does not appear okay das ist irgendein
bug von cross cross platform bild ach shit das geht anscheinend nicht okay das ist jetzt
irgendein .net bug wenn man cross platform bilds macht ja okay das ist ehrlich gesagt nur halb so
schlimm also wenn man eine ernste sagen wir mal eine ernsthafte anwendung baut dann baust du ja
nicht lokal einfach für alle betriebssysteme selbst sondern lässt es irgendeinen bild
server machen und der startet dann halt in den windows krempel und bildet das darauf aber es
ist schon maximal nervig dass das nicht funktioniert aber gut zu wissen okay das
ist prinzipiell kein problem kein problem von mir ja publish genau also wir sind nicht die
einzigen die dieses problem haben guck mal und microsoft interessiert das überhaupt alter die
haben über 5000 issues offen okay ich darf mich nicht beschweren ich habe viel kleinere projekte
und und bearbeite keine issues aber okay aber fünf aber 5000 ist wirklich ordentlich wine.net
installieren und wine.net publish okay die die idee ist nicht verkehrt die ist die ist nicht
schlecht arbeitest du eigentlich als fulltime programmierer nee nee nee mach ich nicht geht
geht moment moment .net geht das überhaupt in wine ordentlich wine powershell kann man
powershell starten in wine ich bräuchte eine command line um den kram zu installieren ich
weiß ich weiß wirklich ich weiß ich habe keine ahnung ladet das setup runter da habe ich jetzt
keinen bock drauf das ist ja abartig ich gehe nicht von windows weg das ist nicht mein ziel
in your csproject add n subsys what das ist nicht mehr supported nee das ist mir das wird zu bescheuert
das mache ich nicht wie kriegt man wie kriegt man mit wine eine command line auf kann man so
was wie wine cmd wine cmd geht so was hey boah poggers kann man jetzt powershell starten nee
man kriegt mit cmd krasser scheiß alter okay .net oder gibt es wie kommt man hier gibt es auch
powershell oder wie heißt das .net install scripts ich habe doch hier curl curl achso
moment wie macht man das unter windows .net cmd wie installiert man das unter windows
das ist powershell wine powershell wie kriege ich eine powershell unter wine winget ja das
gibt es hier bestimmt nicht unter nein nein nein how to install powershell on wine nee leute leute
das mache ich nicht das ist komplett bescheuert keine das braucht keine sau braucht das wer
braucht ein bild lokal jetzt einfach nur für den konsolen window und unter wine man würde es
normalerweise eh nicht so machen würde es normalerweise eh nicht so machen man hätte
irgendeinen bildserver der das teil für einen baut und dann hätte man im zweifelsfall irgendeine vm
mit einem runner oder so drauf der das für mich macht wenn es unbedingt windows sein muss es ist
natürlich schon ziemliche abfuck dass das nicht funktioniert wenn man sich nämlich hier mal das
da anguckt interessiert die jungs das bei microsoft nicht also immer da passiert ist issue seit vier
jahren ja das gibt es nicht ne ok microsoft hat kein bock drauf ja icrosoft hat kein bock drauf
ansonsten müsste man sich wirklich überlegen wie man wie man beispielsweise powershell in wine zum
laufen bekommt und da drin dann .net installieren gibt es powershell exe was ist das es ist mir zu
weh das war aber nicht ja mein issue auf dem achten .net milestone das aber microsoft juckt
das juckt das nicht so wirklich gibt es nicht kann das sein dass er doch versucht was zu starten
der versucht was zu starten aber das funktioniert nicht sehe ich das richtig der versucht powershell
exe zu starten aber er kann das nicht er kann das nicht starten powershell wine ich meine ich gebe
zu das ist ziemlich wine tricks .net was ist wine tricks alles klar noch mal schnell .net
installieren ist das abartig nee mit docker fällt mir das da auch nichts ein also mir würde nur
irgendwas einfallen halt mit sagen wir irgendwie github actions und dann bräuchtest du den eigenen
runner in der windows 4m ja ja ich will die microsoft ich will die volle microsoft experience
jetzt da bin ich mal gespannt auf powershell danach läuft wenn ich .net 6 wobei nee ich
muss ich muss wine wine tricks jetzt ist es jetzt ist es broken guck mal jetzt haben wir es kaputt
gemacht jetzt jetzt geht es nicht mehr aber das ist das ist nicht das ist nicht wild also was
geht so ab ich versuche gerade powershell und wine zum laufen zu bekommen aber an sich ist keine so
schlaue idee wir sollten lieber noch ein bisschen mit unserer mit unserer app rum basteln was wir
da machen können moin michael 50 billionen auch wieder am start chat wer hat eine 5 hat idee was
was können wir was können wir noch einbauen was ist easy also ja ich weiß was ich einbauen genau
also so ein paar sachen gucken was es für controls gibt wir gucken uns mal an was es für
controls gibt gibt es gibt es zum beispiel ein browser control das wäre noch ganz interessant
sound sound am spiel stelle ich mir eklig vor ich glaube nicht dass das geht aber lohnt ja
sound alter geht mir reddit auf den sack mann ok man muss ein embedded voll c player nehmen
was das high level audio engine ja es ist das man nicht übertreiben weil ich glaube wir sehen
heute hier keine dort net installation mehr cancel der protest ist so dumm naja an sich
ich verstehe das voll und ganz ja ich finde die änderung von reddit auch bescheuert aber
im endeffekt wird es wahrscheinlich darauf raus laufen dass irgendwie andere leute die
reddit was hast already been install stimmte überhaupt nicht okay was jetzt installiert
das jetzt doch wie jetzt eben wollte sondern noch nicht ins das ist schon hardcore wird
schimpf sachen unter wein laufen zu lassen das muss das müssen wir nicht umfragen da müssen
wir keine umfrage starten wahrscheinlich hat niemand pauschal in wein laufen weil es total
bescheuerte idee ist jetzt habe ich vergessen was was wollte ich machen jetzt hat mich die
wein geschichte abgelenkt die audio wollte ich nicht mal anflips wollen ich wollte gucken was
es so für was es so für controls gibt also dass man kurz gibt es einen browser gibt es
einen browser webview oder sowas das ist natürlich doof abalonia webview third party
das ist das ist immer so ein ding das für mich so eines der standardchecks für ui frameworks
haben sie in den aktuellen webview du brauchst das nicht so oft wenn du desktop anwendung machst
aber manchmal ist ein webview nicht verkehrt sei es auch nur für irgendwelche authentifizierung
geschichten ja login mit zwei faktor authentifizieren brauchst du manchmal den webview
ganz ohne webview ist doof und ehrlich gesagt sowas sollte als offizielles control in dem
projekt drin sein aber dann musst du chrome schippen und keiner will das nur warum nicht
warum nicht es ist ja es ist doch nicht so als wäre es irgendwie großartige problematik wenn
diese wenn das auf dem desktop keine ahnung 100 mb mehr braucht und gerade für zwei faktor
authentifizierung wie willst du sonst machen ja das ist ja das ist ein third party control
das ist doof für eine hello world app warum nicht es geht doch darum was um zu gucken was
eingebaut ist dass der hello world keine zwei faktor authentifizierung braucht was anderes
aber braucht es für zwei faktor authentifizierung die haben sie sie die haben keinen kein webbrowser
okay dann probieren wir was anderes man kann doch für zwei faktor authentifizierung auf
webbrowser nehmen ja das geht du musst dann halt irgendeinen browser starten der auf dem
system installiert ist mit den passenden mit der passenden url und dann das machen lassen
zurück macht wischtel studio code ja genauso wenn du dich einloggen willst ok.net framework
has finished install ok powershell funktioniert kein powershell unter unter wine dann probieren
wir was anderes wie sieht es denn mit einem filepicker dialog aus das wäre das wäre auch
nicht schlecht mich würde interessieren welchen der unter linux standardmäßig benutzt filepicker
dialog aber lohnt ja filepicker open file dialog ok ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ehrlich gesagt
wie ich das starten soll jetzt hier on click file dialog ist deprecated use window storage
provider api or top level storage provider api top level gibt es nicht das so wird es ja
wahrscheinlich nicht sein ich weiß nicht wie ich das starte gescheit so wird es so wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht sein das startet auch nix ist obsolete use window storage provider api
or top level storage provider ja aber das gibt es ja nicht top level storage top level
muss ich muss ich dem window einen namen geben einen namen geben vielleicht x x name window
und jetzt sagen window window storage provider returns true if it's possible to open the file
picker on the current platform open open file picker async ja wunderbar file picker options
keine bin mal gespannt ob das funktioniert ey guck mal da file picker opent sich das ist nice
dass das so easy funktioniert ok schau mal schau mal gut gut ok file picker weil so ein paar native
controls braucht man immer file picker ist eins davon was haben wir was haben die dinger sonst
noch so zu bieten storage provider open file picker open folder bookmark open folder picker
sowas unter sowas unter linux aus was ist denn ein folder picker versus einen file picker genau
das gleiche bloß in dem anderen verzeichnis nice oder filtert nur auf folder i get files
von pass ok nice nice file picker und so funktioniert bin ich bin ich begeistert
dass sie das ordentlich unterstützen das ist das ist gut das gefällt mir so was haben wir
denn sonst noch so für controls zeigt mal hier border button button spinner was macht das
represents a spinner control that includes to wie sieht das aus button spinner was ist daran
jetzt bitteschön in spinner das ist sogar problem was ist daran jetzt ein spinner das
ist ein ganz normales ja so scroll ding message box können wir gleich mal gucken autocomplete box
represents a control that provides a text box for user input in a drop down that contains
interessant das ist cool dass sie das standardmäßig dabei haben sehr nice sehr nice kalender guck mal
die haben sogar ein kalender date picker ich hoffe die benutzen die benutzen das native
kontrollen kalender tatsächlich kommen ja im kalender ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal so schlecht
gar nicht so übel date picker sieht so aus ok ja das ist gar nicht mal so kacke es sieht so
ein bisschen aus wie windows 311 hier aber für das das ist das ist eigentlich ganz nice der
ungestylte date picker im browser sieht noch schlimmer aus das ist doch echt in ordnung für
eingebaut in meinen stylen kann man den ja selbst wenn man da scharf drauf ist es wäre noch cool
hätten sie irgendwie paar bilder so dabei wir gehen mal kurz documentation version 10 controls
da gab es nämlich mehr zu sehen ja geil man sieht aber auch keine bilder buttons ok wenn es da keine
bilder bei geprägt das auch nix karussell was klasse datacrit das ist für die klassischen
hässlichen windows desktop anwendungen hauptsache hauptsache 5000 sachen im fenster drop down file
dialog jetzt hatten wir schon krit kontextmenü ja gibt es ein kontextmenü das wäre in der
tat ganz interessant kontextmenü die frage ist nur einfach so ja super das das ploppt jetzt auf
an der stelle wo man das nicht haben will das müsste ich irgendwie an die maustaste binden
können das funktioniert anders anders anderweitig warum nicht auf der was soll ich auf der twitch
kommen will ich dass die franzosen mein auto anzünden oder was pop up message gibt es eine
message box aber lohnt ja oder alert oder dialog das was war das system dialog wie
ging das jetzt noch mal window storage dialog wie macht man ein pop-up aber lohnt ja alert box
message box how to show a message box message box show ok wir haben keine native message boxes
anscheinend dass ich mir selbst eine message box bauen kann dem bin ich mir auch im klaren es gibt
community packages für native message boxen ok ich würde diese xml kram mich nervt er auch also
vor allem das hier ich war das ist ja mal richtig abfuck so einen button zu stylen auf der anderen
seite mit wir sollten uns jetzt da vielleicht nicht ganz so sehr lustig drüber machen ernsthaft
ich glaube wenn man sich daran gewöhnt hat und in dieser denkweise so halbwegs drinne ist ist
das gar nicht so schlimm oder chat was sagt ihr für mal alle fragen alle die viel wpf benutzen
falls wir welche haben wie pf 6 herz man gewöhnt sich wahrscheinlich dran oder findet man es
irgendwann wirklich gut oder gewöhnt man sich plus dran einmal gewöhnen sich nicht dran
das ist praktisch tap control ok moment hier man ist mal hier tap control da kommt das ganze
ding hier rein ups tap control kann kann man den kramer please irgendwie ordentlich formatieren
tap control jetzt brauchen tap item ich kann ich mal tippen und wie geht man dem jetzt namen
circle ja das ist natürlich praktisch jetzt haben wir verschiedene jetzt haben wir verschiedene
taps da oben das schon mal ganz nice ok dann haben wir noch was anderes tap item jetzt haben
wir zwei ok das geht nicht doppelt ok das ist mir auch klar dass man das nicht doppelt machen kann
ja tap item heckel oder ja text block 0w meine gute editor geht auf den keks
0w ja ja 2 2 das ist 1 cool das finde ich nice taps kann man eigentlich immer gebrauchen ist
vielleicht für desktop anwendung ein bisschen zu webby aber praktisch taps sind immer nice
aber so wie font setzen font family monospace das funktioniert weil jetzt sind die taps auch
immer gleich breit aber die schriftart sagt halt ok das probieren wir uns noch ein letztes mal
nochmal aus mit der geschichte unter windows ob das damit dann auch alles funktioniert bild
ja windows dann machen wir mal hier tuner auf den downloads ordner löschen das bildverzeichnis und
schieben das wieder rüber das hat echt praktisch an so einer vm bild getting started app tatsächlich
gucke mal der ist ja sogar dass ich einen dark theme verwende seht ihr das der checkt auch
dass ich dass ich ein dark theme habe unter windows unter linux wusste der wahrscheinlich
wusste er ist nicht besser aber unter windows erst kennt er standardmäßig dass ich ein dark
theme habe und fängt erst gar nicht an hier mich zu flashbang ich also ich muss echt sagen mir
gefällt das mir gefällt diese extra wurst in den xml datei nicht so richtig aber an sich finde
ich das wirklich cool kannst du damit auch fensterlose overlays machen fensterlose overlays
erfordern sehr viel windows spezifische sachen weiß ich nicht ob man das alles setzen kann in
afalonia gerade dass die sachen transparent sind ist super kompliziert gewesen unter windows ich
habe wir können wir können mal gucken ob man window border 0 afalonia window borderless
style bei setting these properties on the window extend client area to decoration hint true extend
client area chrome hints non chrome ok wenn das wenn stack overflow das sagt und wir wissen ja
prinzipiell dass stack overflow immer recht hat was sowas angeht gut unter linux haben wir ja
gar keine fenster tuner ok schauen wir mal fensters weg komm mal da borderless so fast
borderless aber aber ohne ohne window drumherum das sieht ehrlich gesagt eine halbwegs modernen
windows anwendung aus ich finde das gut gemacht von denen ja das mit dem mit dem konsolenfenster
so schon ein bisschen ätzend aber ist nicht schlecht also ganz ehrlich ich ich glaube damit
könnte ich leben wir testen jetzt noch mal eine sache wie das hiermit ist afalonia ist das aot
kompatibel wahrscheinlich nicht doch ok aot schauen wir mal was da passiert da bin ich ja mal
gespannt ob das klappt es gibt schon mal 30 milliarden fehler nicht fehler meine warnings
aber es hat gebaut achso ne was war das hier include include das haben wir ja gebraucht
aber mal einen test jetzt da das app ok leute native native aot wird schon unterstützt
schlecht ich muss den bildordner noch mal löschen vorher das funktioniert jetzt nicht
native und aot und embedden und so funktioniert nicht ok kann man auch verstehen da gibt es ja
nichts zu embedden wir können noch eine sache mal probieren man kannte doch .net compress compress
konnte doch sagen dass das ne compress enable single file compression das machen wir weg
true strip symbols true ach ne moment single publish single file ja die die compile parameter
sind echt ppger wir löschen nochmals output mal gucken wie groß das jetzt ist am ende das
mal schauen ich bin mal gespannt strip symbols enable compression sondern am ende ist das wie
groß 43 mb das geht doch voll klar oder was meint ihr also ich finde 43 mb für eine desktop
anwendung geht voll klar startet auch schon schnell schnell genug das ist jetzt nichts
was ich 50 mal in der sekunde starten und stoppen würde wie groß ist das bild so gute frage aber
das ist ziemlich low res gift 32k doch doch self-contained guck hier es ist nur das hier
was wir haben das sind die bug symbols das ist egal das ist in 43 mb anwendung die kann ich
jetzt so kopieren und starten und da funktioniert die auch ich würde sagen ich zeige es euch aber
es ist eine grafische anwendung ich kann die nicht einfach im docker container starten und zeigen
guck mal hier funktioniert du musst das dotnet framework dafür installiert haben muss ich nicht
muss ich nicht das ist embedded hier drin publish single doch noch publish single file ist
self-contained du kannst es gar nicht mehr in kombination angeben aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen
das ist der minimal hallo world app also wenn da noch einiges dazu kommt wird es wahrscheinlich
noch bedeutend größer werden aber da ist schon das komplette schon die komplette dotnet run time
drin und alle library sachen und so die ich verwende also das geht eigentlich komplett klar
das ist in ordnung kurz gucken was selbst was hier im chat so abgeht ram zu ich schaffe auch
nie mein ram voll zu bekommen guck ram usage 37 von 63 ja keine ahnung was microsoft da schreibt
aber das ist das ist selbst selbstcontained auf jeden fall was schon eben unter windows gesehen
hast weil ich habe unter windows gar keinen dort nicht installiert also dass das wäre auch bei
weitem nicht so groß wenn da nicht das framework drinnen wäre ich habe ich immer abstand gehalten
von er musste alles dass xml dto nie hör mal bloß auf muss ich muss ich nicht lernen aber ganz
ehrlich alles was xml basiert ist ist eigentlich ziemlicher schrott also auch html aber so xml zum
datenaustausch ist halt echt abfuck xml an sich hat ja alles irgendwo noch seine daseinsberechtigung
aber xml zum datenaustausch was du als response von irgendwelchen apis kriegst oder sowas das ist
sowas von 2003 erinnert sich noch jemand an soap also wem plottet xml noch nicht gereicht hat
er sollte sich mal soap xml angucken ein schönes beispiel ja sowas ja exzellente soap xml response
2003 ja es war so ungefähr ungefähr 2003 2007 und so kam dann schon jason langsam auf 2007 8 jason
first version release states ok 2001 das hat aber noch keiner verwendet außer innerhalb von javascript
objekt zum datenaustausch kam das so ab 2007 oder so dann langsam auf du bekommst 32 g nicht
voll ganz einfach du musst viele java anwendungen starten in deiner vm dann ist das kein ding weil
dann braucht deine vm ausschritt meine vm braucht nicht so viel meine vm hat auch nur 24 g warum
habe ich denn überhaupt so viel verbraucht dann was verbraucht denn bei mir viel so viel memory
wo sieht man das weiß man nicht windows nämlich veräppelt dass das sind keine
20 als sind keine 37 gigabyte was ich hier sehe habe ich noch eine vm laufen vielleicht
auf meinem zweiten account das könnte sein aber vor allem am workstation steht da taucht
doch hier gar nicht auf das stimmt doch schon mal irgendwas nicht nach keine ahnung windows
logik was ist denn die alternative zu nix nix nix html ist das einzige sinnvolle es gibt ja
mittlerweile solche sachen wie blazer und sowas die dann mit mit mit web assembly irgendwelche
sachen laufen lassen wurde dann kein html mehr schreiben muss unter der haube weiß ich übrigens
gar nicht wie die wie wird blazer eigentlich im browser gerendert in einem canvas oder wie
funktioniert das weil weil web assembly hat ja erst mal nix mit dem seiteninhalt zu tun
renner das dann auch in html raus weil im browser kann halt einfach nichts anderes anzeigen als
html außer halt ein html canvas element wo du selbst sachen drin malst also ich hab mal ich
ich hab mal blazer versucht da hat man kein html erstellt da konnte man irgendeinen button
erstellen aber es ist aber nicht in html wenn ich mich richtig erinnere wobei doch in html ne
du hast recht das ist doch in html das war diese razor page syntaxe da du hast oben html gemacht
und konntest dann konntest das irgendwie mit mit mit sich zusammenwürsten hast du htmx gesehen
das ist ja irgendein javascript zeug was was dir erlaubt deine seiten ein bisschen interaktiv zu
machen das ist ja ist ja nix was ein browser unterstützt ja das ist wenn du selber seitlich
laufen lässt aber du kannst ja auch web assembly machen mit blazer da hat mich wie es da gerendert
wird müssen wir uns glaube ich in nächster zeit auch mal wieder angucken wähle mal benutzer aus
im task manager also das ist ziemlich agil was hier angezeigt wird das müssen die vm sein die
laufen das ist gut wenn die das so machen weil das war eines meiner kritikpunkte oder meiner
hauptsächlichen kritikpunkte an blazer bisher dass es halt immer ewig dauert weil du irgendwie
du musstest glaube ich das letzte mal ich kam musstest du über 8 mb oder am anfang war sogar
über über 14 mb oder das dort netrun time runterladen vielleicht ist es mittlerweile noch
ein bisschen kleiner aber die idee ist nah ist das so zu machen übrigens kleiner sellout am rande ja
es ist ja noch ziemlich am anfang des monats achtet mal drauf dass ihr euren primes ab nicht
verfallen lasst bist nicht feinfertig genug ja ich auch nicht irgendwelche high IQ diskussionen
vorhin übersehen fminister dankeschön für den sub ist ein bisschen sellout lohnt sich immer das
kann sein dass das wegen dem dark theme gewesen ist ja naja so haben wir noch irgendwelche
controls zum ausprobieren was was gibt es denn noch was was was würde mich denn jetzt noch mal
hier interessieren dran ja canvas kann man was selbst malen kann man das ist auch immer wichtig
canvas kann man was selbst malen ja aber bitte schön nicht nicht in stemmel sondern im code ok
das testen wir jetzt mal kurz weil hier canvas x warum ist das eigentlich x name das habe ich
nie gecheckt in wpf canvas benutzt man das jetzt on point ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht es
gibt sowas wie on draw wo ich dann was ändern kann kann man da nicht komplette 3d render action
mal ich weiß nicht auf was ich das bezieht wieso funktioniert das mit dem canvas schon mal nicht
gehen wir noch mal hier auf die docs api avalonia canvas ich hätte jetzt ich hätte jetzt eigentlich
es gibt ein event beim canvas was automatisch aufgerufen wird alle tja jeden frame wahrscheinlich
60 60 mal in der sekunde hätte ich jetzt hätte ich jetzt erwartet ich sehe hier aber nix hier
gibt es nur mouse events pointer press nee ich will da selbst was rein malen was gibt es anscheinend
avalonia canvas on draw how to draw directly on a canvas aber muss ein eigenes control machen
dafür ok ja das das ergibt sinn das ist sehr wpf style mäßig ja ok man muss man muss ein eigenes
control machen oder habe ich jetzt keinen bock drauf auch wenn es anscheinend gar nicht so
kompliziert aussieht ich meine public class kackel control jetzt override drawer render
render kontext draw line draw rectangle wie trotman a rectangle pen brush
but rush green ok excellent draw a rectangle calculate a new point
was das rectangle hatten die corner radius hat das new rekt get rekt position 0.0 200
pixel ok nice exzellent das control und wie kann ich jetzt das da reinpacken kackel
control ja muss irgendwie gehen aber da muss ich den namespace inkluden für ok und malte
jetzt eine rektangel der mal wahnsinn funktioniert einfach ok so macht man also eigene controls das
ist in der tat recht easy falls man zwar braucht ja also in der regel braucht man das ja nicht
aber ab und zu kann es durchaus sein dass man einen eigenen kram malen muss in irgendwelche
könnte ich jetzt zum beispiel auch sagen wir mal einen button machen jetzt habe ich den jetzt habe
ich den selbstgebauten button tatsächlich ich habe sogar den schatten drumherum weil
er funktioniert nicht oder macht auch nix aber ok das funktioniert ok warum gibt es eine klasse die
ernsthaft kontrolls heißt danke für den sub huge subscription exzellent feifert richtig richtig
ja ich habe auch als gedacht rektangel hat einen radius aber nein es ist ein border radius man
weiß nie man weiß nie was sich manche leute so ausdenken da gibt es bestimmt auch rechtecke mit
einem radius eine frage welche aktien hast du ich habe ganz viele aktien aber ich kümmere mich
nicht drum weil ich ein etf gekauft habe in dem ganz viele aktien drin sind und weil ich überhaupt
keinen plan davon habe davon habe muss man kurz was testen was gucken ok passt alles ok wo sind
wir stehen geblieben ja genau ich mache mich da ich war mir da gar keine großen gedanken drüber
die strongs sind wieder ein bisschen runtergegangen aber das juckt mich nicht ich werde das ein aber
heute ist immer so das jahr über sind sie schon wieder hoch gegangen aber insgesamt ich behalte
das einfach jetzt für 20 jahre oder so und ich bezahle auch immer wieder zwischendurch was ein
und dann jetzt big stonks jeden monat einzahlen ja aber eher ein bisschen unregelmäßiger und
dafür ein bisschen mehr so alle paar monate aber dann halt auch ein bisschen mehr als ich
habe beispielsweise 5000 euro einbezahlt vor am 6 also vor zwei tagen ich mache das
öfters aber unregelmäßig ich habe ich habe keinen festen plan so nach dem motto 500 euro im monat
ich habe gerade was getrunken erinnerung ok leute haben wir noch irgendwas was wir bauen können mir
fällt gerade ehrlich gesagt nichts mehr ein ich meine ich werde jetzt hier keine wirklich sinnvolle
anwendungen die irgendwas tolles macht bauen können es hat ungefähr zwei jahren oder so
etf stelz ich habe jetzt erst angefangen vor ja wie gesagt vor zwei jahren oder vielleicht schon
drei jahren also nicht nicht lange her ich habe jetzt erst angefangen wieder gedanken
drum zu machen ich meine ich war damals dann irgendwie 36 oder 37 oder sowas ja so 36 und
ich meine es ist natürlich immer sinnvoll man fängt also umso früher man anfängt aber nicht
desto trotz ist es besser jetzt noch anzufangen als gar nichts mehr zu machen außerdem kann ich
dann auch gleich mit mehr kohle starten probier mal irgendwie text output als file picker wo du
eine textdatei auswählst ok gute idee das können wir es auch probieren da war ein komisches control
wieder weg und das kommt auch hier weg file picker so also das heißt wenn wir auf den button klicken
da kommt nicht nur so mehr kommt dann auch noch wie ging das jetzt noch mal window storage picker
file picker async new file picker options was ist denn was return der file picker überhaupt ein
i-storage file okay file await aber das noch richtig schreiben könnten async gibt es jetzt
was eine read only file list ja gut man könnte ja mehrere sachen aber gut uns interessiert ja
eigentlich nur die erste also hier file first wir gehen einfach mal davon aus dass es immer eine
ausgewählte datei gibt wir können auch sagen files sollte man das hier vielleicht nennen
files längst größer 0 dann öffnen wir das erste file und gucken rein und holen uns den fad raus
und öffnen den ok probieren wir aus wir machen hier blubb punkt txt omega 0 ja gut genau das so
perfekt so will ich das haben sondern brauchen wir eine textbox textbox anstelle von wir machen
einfach noch eine textbox dabei ja textbox perfekt genau genau exakt da will ich die haben beste
textbox überhaupt x name textbox so langsamer sicher müsste ich mir mal gescheite namen für
ausdenken ich habe ja noch extra textbox ok ok textbox gleich textbox was ist denn textbox text
ok jetzt müssen wir erst mal die datei einlösen ein einlesen also file read hups
file ach das da will ich haben read all text was warum will er das nicht was hat er für schmerzen
uri ist not assignable to string ich glaube absolut muss man daneben und not not sicher
ss und overload ok text so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert was ich da gestrickt
habe also man kann einfach zu spring machen klickt wie er den start hat blubb txt
und feind part of path warum nicht was das ok wie kriege ich denn hier local path was muss
ich davon nehmen jetzt einen umgedreht local path local path muss es sein zack omega kek
lol funktioniert wir lesen mal das debian iso kurz ein oder es hat nicht funktioniert
debian iso einlesen war nicht erfolgreich oh meine app ist gecrasht es war keine gute idee
das debian iso einzulesen dass das hat ich nicht gefallen da müsste ich vielleicht bei
dem die size und den filetype checken vor allem vor allem bevor ich das komplette iso in ram
einlesen dass das finde das ding nicht so geil glaube ich der ist ziemlich beschäftigt gerade
der versuch gerade debian iso da muss das komplette debian iso als text lesen und dann
an die textbox anhängen die anwendung ist komplett kaputt und gefräst jetzt ist auch kaputt
f man kann es ja nicht mal beenden mehr x kill ohne ist das nicht jetzt ist gecrasht ja das
funktioniert also man müsste eigentlich noch checken kann ich auch mal zeigen wie man das
macht was was stand übrigens hier drin ist well format uri string das würde ich jetzt mal von
ausgehen dass es das ist aber man kann man kann zum beispiel sagen man den fahrrad new file info
da kann man den fahrrad übergeben ach ne local path was kann das hier übergeben und dann könnte
man dann könnte man gucken ja file info if info exist das wäre schon mal sinnvoll und info
extension ja extension ist jetzt eigentlich an der stelle nicht das richtige weil es kann ja
auch punkt txt sein und tja es ist binary da müsst ihr jetzt eigentlich gucken ob wir irgendwie den
type raus kriegt dann bin ich mir aber gar nicht sicher wie man das macht macht man das nicht vom
file extension determin file type in c sharp ja content type get content type im moment anhand
des filen names ja das ist ja ppga methode schlechthin das ist eine gute frage das habe
ich glaube ich noch nie gemacht ja guckt die machen das alles mit der extension aber eigentlich
ist es mit der extension hyper ppga man bräuchte irgend so eine meinem type library ich meine wir
können es wir können es wir können es ja so machen dass es mal dass es mal zumindest nicht
crashed ja wir gucken if info also im file exists und info size kriegt man das size raus
length get the size in bytes okay ja und alles über irgendwie vier kilobyte oder also alles
muss unter vier kilobyte sein also dass das funktioniert dann schon mal aber schöner wäre
es natürlich und da fällt mir jetzt gibt es garantiert fertige libraries für die file type
erkennung macht ja genau man bräuchte eine library die file header checkt oder unter linux
irgendwas was halt auf sowas hier zurück greift sie schafft meinem lib library meinem kit
nochmal da passive support vor nee moment das ist was anderes das ist was anderes das ist
mail type checker aber da muss es da muss es bisschen größere projekte für geben das kann
ich mir eigentlich vorstellen macht jedoch chat gpt ja sowas genau sowas in der richtung hätte ich
jetzt auch erwartet da gibt es doch garantiert bisschen irgendwelche größeren lips für
extension sagt halt ja das habe ich auch gefunden ich hätte jetzt aber eigentlich erwartet dass da
ein bisschen größere bekanntere libraries für gibt zumindest haben wir es jetzt erst mal gefixt
wir haben es jetzt erst mal gefixt indem wir nur kleine dateien erlauben also ich kann jetzt zwar
das debian iso auswählen aber dann passiert nichts mehr das geht geht einfach geht einfach
nicht aber wenn ich was kleines auswähle dann jetzt da code project das bringt mich ich brauche
irgendwie viel da muss es irgendeine da muss es irgendwelche größeren bekannten bekannteren
libraries für geben ja das ist ja nicht sonderlich bekannt also ja der fiat champ hat mehr sterne aber
sowas an sowas in der richtung daran habe ich gedacht ja halt was nicht nach extensions geht
sondern also das geht ja nicht nach extensions sondern nach file header und sowas ja ich werde
mal unter linux hin ist es relativ easy da kann ich einfach auf könig einfach file exec und gucken
was rauskommt als signatures ja genau gibt gibt einige libraries in der richtung das finde ich
eigentlich das finde ich eigentlich ganz nett hier an der stelle weil man sagen kann ist image das
heißt ich kann dann sagen ist text hoffe ich mal ja weil stream und dann würde ich sagen ist text
als es sowas gibt aber so viel erkennt das auch nicht ich hätte auch gerne dass der csv und so
erkennt dass man theoretisch stand ist egal vollkommen wurscht machen wir jetzt nicht mal
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen schicker so kann man wenigstens lesen alles klar das reicht exzellent
mir reicht heute überlegt habe ich noch alles esse pepo fett und unschlüssig also wenn ich
ein eis esse dann esse ich meistens drei kugeln leicht pepperwurz eis oder oder whatsapp eis
oder elsa eiskönigin eis ja bei uns in der in der eisdiele gibt es whatsapp eis und spiderman
eis und pepperwurz eis im prinzip sind das halt ganz normale eissorten die halt für kinder gemacht
sind vom namen her wobei pepperwurz eis hat sogar so schweine nase drauf im eis welches kind sagt
ja man whatsapp eis wahrscheinlich genug ich könnte mir vorstellen dass gerade bei kleineren
kindern pepperwurz eis deutlich beliebter ist onlyfans eis du ich glaube bei passenden stellen
gibt es das schon in den richtigen kreisen c++ eis ja endlich was was ich mir kaufen würde da
hätte c++ wenigstens auch mal eine positive seite ansonsten ist ja so ziemlich alles paints champ an
c++ kubernetes wonach schmeckt whatsapp eis eigentlich weiß ich das ist halt einfach nur
grün ich habe das noch nicht ausprobiert also insofern so ich gehe jetzt wirklich was futtern
oder zumindest gucken ob ich eis esse ich weiß ja nicht genau aber auf jeden fall sehen wir uns
spätestens morgen früh um halb neun bis neun wöchentliche aufwachen streben ich
habe euch gefallen bis dann macht's gut zu